there's a lot in the news today and we
are not going to talk about any of it
because who cares it's something about a
memo lying Democrat same story different
day instead we will analyze feminism
right down to its cold frigid bra
burning core with PJ Media columnist and
Disney Princess enthusiast faith more
one question which is the greater
fiction snow white or feminism then the
mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
I am so excited to get to this today we
actually we dug deep into the daily wire
archives we found some incredible
historical footage of what women were
like before feminism and and then also
obviously what women are like after
feminism we have to talk about all of it
we have a wonderful thinker and writer
on the show today before we get to any
of that that we have to talk about
shaving we have to this is something you
know maybe I'll read a book or I'll
think about some important idea once a
week once every seven weeks something
like that but I shave every single day
so you've heard me talk of the amazing
shave I get from my Dollar Shave Club
razor especially when I use it with
there dr. Carver's shaved butter well I
am here to tell you that I'm never
giving up my membership in fact I'm
adding even more DSC products to my
daily routine Dollar Shave Club makes
products for your hair face skin shower
everything you need it is the best razor
I've ever used and I actually buy nice
razors this is so good they have me
looking and feeling great it's all of
their own original stuff they use only
the finest premium ingredients and they
deliver it to you so it's just like with
all of the the razors they started out
with razors and instead of having to go
to the pharmacy and up and down the
aisle and then you know you go into that
aisle that men aren't supposed to go
into and you feel very weird and creepy
and you look around no one's so I mean
you don't forget about any of that stuff
you can get be like a normal person in
the 21st century and you can order this
online you'll come right to your door
it's very inexpensive there are no more
annoying trips to the store I use Dollar
Shave Club for almost everything razors
body cleanser hair gels they even have
this new product which guys so in Europe
you know Europeans are they're very
interested in being clean everywhere not
just like we rugged Americans who are
clean most places so they have an
invention called a bidet and it allows
you to clean where the Sun don't shine
well in America if you don't want to
have a giant bidet installed in your
house that's a very expensive sort of
thing you probably have to go to the
store for that and pick it out you can
just use wipes for your derriere that
come to you from Dollar Shave Club
they're very effective so I'm told now
it is a great time to give Dollar Shave
Club
try you can get your first month of
their best razor and it's a really
really good razor along with travel
sized versions of shave butter body
cleanser and yes even that derriere
cleaner for just $5 this is basically
free if you have ever bought an even
sort of nice razor even what a bag of
those terrible little disposable ones
it's more than five dollars so just get
this it's basically free after that
replacement cartridges ship for just a
few bucks a month
it is the DSC starter kit get yours for
just five dollars exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash coffe FA Co V
Fe Fe that is dollarshaveclub.com slash
co FFA what is it Marshall Dollar Shave
Club comm slash FFA okay excellent now
we talk about history a lot on the show
you know that so consider this a mini
this day in history segment because the
archivists at the daily wire have dug up
incredible footage showing what women
used to look like before
feminism let's see it
I'm sorry I didn't mean to fight me but
you don't know what I've been through
and all because I was afraid I'm so
ashamed
[Music]
chirp-chirp sure that was so nice that
was like watching a cartoon sweet little
ELISA so we don't Lisa is very
fair-skinned it was just like what a
beautiful and now also I'm sorry you had
to come out of it now let's take a look
at what feminism has turned women into
it doesn't stand for women's rights I
get my camera out of my face see what I
am the feminist who is out to ruin your
I am the feminist who is ruining your
perfectly respectful marriage by
suggesting Audrey Lorde to the book club
that your wife attends and yes I am the
one who convinced her to get that
shorter haircut that you pretend to like
but don't really like I am the feminist
who is pushing your daughter down the
slippery slope of [ __ ] hood but giving
her a high five when she says she keeps
her own supply of condoms and
incidentally I've tried to turn her
bisexual gay by recommending some dental
dams yes that's progress
there it is there's the progress
everybody what an advancement how
enlightened now we are what wonderful
things feminism has brought to the world
we have to bring on now faith more a
wonderful writer about all things
feminist and more importantly a Disney
Princess addict faith thank you for
coming on hi thanks for having me it's
great to be here so faith my first
question which is more of a fantasy
Disney or feminism feminism no feminism
is based on a lie it's based on the lie
that men and women are the same that
gender is a social contract that's a lie
Disney tells the truth about women and
what's so strange about it too is that
is the central lie men and women are the
same they're indistinguishable and yet
it's called feminism they always say
well it just means men and women they
deserve the same rights or whatever but
then why is it called feminism it's that
we have a philosophy for that which is
called egalitarianism so it seems on the
one hand it says men and women are
exactly the same and on the other hand
women are this totally separate
categorical entity and we need to give
them everything and
them yell at us and kick our signs down
well not only that it also ends up
saying that men are actually better than
women because if you say that gender is
a social construct and men and women are
exactly the same but everything that is
feminine is because of the oppression of
men so women have to act more like men
that means men are better than women
everything within the category of woman
is a lesser and worse and terrible right
given that given and it's funny because
given the premise if men and women
really are no different then there are
no women right then there isn't a
categorical distinction between men and
women it's just it's just men and men
with long hair who look nicer now faith
you love Disney Princesses you have a
pretty big Facebook page about this
you'll write about this frequently why
do you love them so I love Disney
Princesses well all girls love Disney
Princesses I mean little girls love
Disney Princess that's the most
controversial statement that has ever
been uttered on my program yeah I'm here
too you just really shake things up with
my Disney princess conversation no I
mean it doesn't matter how much
feminists try to convince us that little
girls don't love princesses they do they
love princesses and the thing about
Disney Princesses is that they're
actually a great they're great role
models for modern girls because they're
they're brave and passionate and
outspoken and they have goals and they
follow their dreams and all these things
but they do it without compromising
their femininity their kindness their
nurturing nature they want love they
want to start a family all of these
things but somewhere along the line
feminists got a hold of the narrative
about Disney Princesses and they did to
the princesses what they do to women
which is that because they act like
women they've decided that they're just
these victim damsels in distress'
husband hunters and we believe them so
the the pub the general public sort of
believes them so anyone who tells you
that they love Disney Princesses
apologizes first they say like I know I
know they're really sorry I'm sorry but
I just really love them you know and
moms like they banned them from their
houses and they're not allowed to like
I'm allowed to watch some of these
things but but really I think in our
current culture in our current situation
situation about gender these are some
really great stories for little girls to
be looking at to figure out how to
become women and you make the point on
damsels in distress that's that's how a
lot of people think of them that's how
to portrayed that they're just waiting
for the man to come around but you say
they're not damsels in distress just
like women before feminism weren't just
helpless damsels in distress what do
these people get wrong so I mean you
just play that whole thing about Snow
White and in fact in that clip that you
played she says I'm so what did she say
I'm so ashamed of the fuss I've made and
so when you think about that right this
is a person who I mean in that scene
she's just been like someone threatened
to kill her essentially and then she ran
away and she can never come home so
that's bad and but she's so ashamed of
the fuss that she's made right and the
next thing that she does is she goes to
a house find that it would be a really
good place to hide out and decides to
make a deal with the people who live
there she is gonna cook and clean for
them because she knows how to do that
and they'll let her stay so I mean if if
feminists want her to be a freeloader
and just get the men in the house to
take care of her then that would be fine
I guess but really what she does is she
actually shows up with a plan that's
right she's not just offering her body
or something she says I have these
skills and I'm gonna make a deal and
strike out on my own and not have to
become some fake man in order to do it
exactly and I think they're they're
almost all like that until you get to
the princesses that are the more recent
ones that are supposed to be more modern
and then you get these princesses who
are sort of like infantilized and
objectified like in their own story
except those are the ones because they
write shoot and that's the new fiction
that they're it were it's not that we're
seeing this throughout all of these
Disney movies and more largely
throughout all of the folk tales and
fables that come to us
through the tradition we're actually
this is a modern advancement that the
women are oppressed that they're this is
an ideological vision that's being
imposed even on these stories even on
these Disney stories how long until we
see a transgendered Disney Princess oh
it's it's coming development right now
yeah I think so I mean we had the first
boy princess but it was it was in a
cartoon on television so I said it
doesn't officially count but yeah I mean
there was a boy who was dressing up as a
girl in order to do something or other
and you know so he was sort of lauded as
Disney's first boy princess oh my gosh I
actually don't follow the you'll be
shocked to hear this I don't follow
Disney very closely I didn't so that
they're already testing into what will
become inevitably the transgender Disney
Princess also known as the end of Disney
Princesses right exactly yeah I mean I
think that's probably that's really
gonna happen I mean there's already
called for Elsa from frozen to be a
lesbian since you know she didn't have a
love interest and all of this stuff so I
mean all of that all of that is coming
and I think you're just gonna lose the
girls you know this is what this is what
happens in the culture generally they
loot they insist on adding this
ideological vision and then they lose
their audience because it's no longer
entertaining it no longer corresponds to
reality as we know reality is we as we
as we see ourselves and as we see other
people in the world and they lose all
the audience but they still win all of
the awards because it's so important man
isn't it so important and powerful right
exactly you know and now we're
essentially telling you know my least
favorite Disney movie of all Disney
princess movie of all time
is brave and brave is a story about not
growing up because they can't they they
can't have her find a husband that I
can't have her you know have her life
they had basically she goes out on the
whole quest that a Disney Princess goes
out on and then ends up right back home
where she started and we have no idea
what's gonna happen to her so that's
that's essentially what's happening is
they're infantilizing women by making it
so that they can't they can't leave home
because there's nothing for them out
there
that's right you knew you know there
there is Peter Pan but Peter Pan is a
sad tale it's a sad thing that Peter
can't grow up and doesn't move on with
his life
and I think this is sort of a right
exactly I think this is kind of a
rationalist this is what happens with
ideologies ideology forgets that we live
in time and we live in space and so they
say this is it this is the frozen moment
but I don't know I really liked college
college was a lot of fun I don't wish
that I were still in college because
that's in the past I like other you know
Ivy was fun to be a child but I don't
wish that I were still a child and they
lose that and and all conservatives I
like to think look at reality as it is
and they understand that we live in time
we live in a space and you can't stay
and never Neverland forever
Lefty's tell us they tell us all the
time that gender is a social construct
but I'm looking at you faith you look
very much like a lady
you seem objectively prettier than I am
your voice is higher pitched than mine
is is there evidence that gender is a
social construct no in fact I think
there's evidence that it is not a social
construct that it is inherent in men to
be men and women to be women and there
are even there are studies that sort of
you know the most recent one I saw was
about sort of toy preference and they
kind of they've they weeded out all of
these things like you know whether the
mom and dad were there and all this
stuff and it was like the girls picked
the girl toys the boy I mean no it's
ridiculous you know I and I think that
when when you try to prove that that
gender is a social construct you you end
up just sort of talking yourself in
circles and when the feminists do it
they end up talking themselves into
victimhood essentially no of course they
it always ironically something that's
supposed to empower them ends up making
them like little children and I love
that you brought up the scientific
studies because I've seen these two
studies that show that regardless of
socialization regardless of the awful
patriarchal culture boys want to play
with boy toys and robot girls won't play
with girl toys and then in fake studies
in like gender studies one of my hobbies
a few years ago a buddy of mine did
and I we did we did this on tumblr we
created a blog called Gender Studies
department ID as always I think it's
still up there Gender Studies department
- blog tumblr com and we would just post
quotes from actual peer-reviewed
published Gender Studies papers that
absolutely meant nothing they were just
random words
and so one quote says and this is by
this might be the most rational quote of
all of them it says at the root of eco
feminism is the understanding that the
many systems of oppression are mutually
reinforcing building on the socialist
feminist insight that racism classism
and sexism are interconnected eco
feminists whatever that is recognized
additional similarities between those
forms of human oppression and the
oppressive structures of speciesism and
naturism and ism ISM and ISM ISM ISM I
notice all of these other lefty ideas
socialism environmentalism they keep
creeping into discussions about feminism
can there be a conservative feminism I
sometimes hear some of my conservative
or my conservative ish female friends
say things like you know a woman with a
gun that yeah with a gun that's real
feminism or a woman CEO raising children
and go and work every day that's
feminism or whatever they say is there a
conservative feminism or are isms and
ideologies like feminism just
incompatible with with conservative
thought well I think that at the heart
of feminism or I guess at the beginning
of feminism I think it began with a
notion that we can all agree with which
is that men and women are equally
valuable to society that that you need
men and women and that you know women
should be allowed to do the same kinds
of things as men if they want to do them
and I think and so I think that if that
were still true about feminism then
maybe we could get behind it more than
then we can now but that that isn't
actually what the feminists now are
saying you know they're not they're not
saying it's that men and women are
equally valuable to size to society
they're saying
that they're the same and that certain
traits be they male or female are
positive or negative I mean the thing is
men have inherently male traits and
women have inherently female traits and
there's no moral judgement about that it
just is mm-hmm so when you start to put
moral judgment on the inherent traits
that's when you get lost and I think
that feminism has gotten lost so I don't
I don't know what the word would be for
someone who thinks rationally but
Christian you know there are some other
versions too rational people yeah I
don't know you know that's absolutely
right there's a the complementarity of
the sexes poses equal value in
Christianity and and Judaism the eve is
plucked out of Adam's rib not out of his
head she's not higher than Adam out of
his foot she's not lower than a time
right out of his rib in the beginning
God created man both male and female he
created them
they've equal dignity but they're
clearly not the same I hope they're not
the same the blogger speaking speaking
of the complementarity of the sexes
we're gonna get a little saucy here
the bloggers Samara over at scary mommy
wrote a piece called sometimes I want to
be held by a man naked without having
sex is that okay the answer is no by the
way she says that women need intimacy in
their lives and therefore they should be
able to expect it from randos that they
hook up with what is wrong with that
can't women have it all no actually
women can't have it all even when they
say when they're referring to the other
thing which is like working and raising
kids they can't have it all in that area
either but um no that is a ridiculous
request because and the reason it's a
ridiculous request is because you don't
actually know that person and therefore
you can't have intimacy with him you can
have an intimate act but you can't have
interesting yet intimate as in like get
it on as in like you know whatever you
want to call that but you can't have
intimacy with that person because you
just met them like an hour ago
and you know now you're upstairs in
their apartment naked and and I think
you know like if if you get naked in
front of someone that
you just met um I think you're basically
sending the message that you would like
to have sex like you're not really
sending the message that you'd like to
just kind of lie there and I don't
always the message I'm trying to send I
don't know if people are misinterpreting
what I'm that's the message you know one
time I went on a date with his ease I'm
sorry and he and I he and I just had
clicked well I'll save it for another
time but we just had very different
views of what was happening you know
well if you'd like to tell me I can
publish it and then I'll keep your name
and good keep it anonymous I not a lot
of people watch the show so I don't
think it'll really get out you know yes
that is that is so right there there is
because you you wrote beautifully on
this topic about how women do long for
these things in a way that men don't oh
I don't want to tell any tales at a
school here folks but it turns out that
men are more comfortable with casual sex
and desire it more than women do broadly
speaking no new you think that me too
speaking of is awful me too
some center-right writers have jumped on
board though they say yes these awful
men they've harassed me too what is
wrong with this slacktivism
me too has sort of devolved into this I
mean I said something really interesting
I think is happening about me too which
is that you know initially it arose I
guess because of all of the really
horrible things that were going on like
Harvey Weinstein and all of those other
people and and people were saying you
know I was really really truly violated
and but it was very very quickly
devolved into yes you know me too
because somebody can't called me on the
street or you know me too because I saw
a man one time or me to just give
Michael nose looks you just kind of laid
out an Italian you got a gold chain it
doesn't like that guy on the subway
looked like he was going to ask for my
number and did it me too so you know
it's kind of that really deal Ajith
amaizing the victims of actual sexual
crimes
right like lumping all of those things
together is really a terrible thing to
do to people that have actually
experienced something horrific but
especially these days there
great currency in victimhood this whole
my mother was more floors for less money
thing
and so you see rape hoaxes you see a
spike in rape hoaxes on campus both
before college and and obviously on
college campuses we've had major uh the
the the vast majority if not all of the
major headline-grabbing rape cases at
universities in the last five years have
come out to be hoaxes beginning with
Duke Lacrosse but all the way up to the
UVA scandal that Rolling Stone
breathlessly reported on without any
evidence there's a lot of currency in
that in that victimhood it seems to say
something about the culture that we're
so proud to be victims it seems that
something is unhealthy in the culture
yeah absolutely and I think I think that
it's all sort of a product of this you
know we're we're so oppressed you know
gender social constructs kind of
mentality because if women are supposed
to behave like men when it comes to sex
and they're supposed to want to have the
kinds of meaningless sex and you know
like swipe in whatever direction on
tinder they're supposed to be swiping
you know then then it's always the fault
of the man if they feel violated right
where they feel uncomfortable in some
way because that wasn't actually what
they wanted to do what they wanted to do
was meet a nice guy and fall in love and
you know get married children so you
know then but it allows you to maintain
the lie by saying that you're the victim
you were victimized something went wrong
this isn't normally how this progresses
this regret is so this is how I'm
supposed to behave I'm supposed to want
this but you know so you did something
wrong and I'm the victim and now we can
maintain the lie right that's absolutely
right
you are happily married so you haven't
fallen victim to this awful trap you're
a stay-at-home mother and you're married
in the old fashioned way this is you're
married in the very old-school way where
you find another person and then join
with them together but that's because
you're not hip enough for Salah gammy
you've heard of Salah gammy in 2006
Alexandre Gill married
herself she had a ceremony for herself
an Italian woman last year Laura Maisy
invited 70 guests to a farmhouse in
Bimmer caught a to Mary herself a 38
year old British woman named Sophie
Tanner in 2015 married herself after her
father and that was after her father had
given her away to herself so sad mhm the
wedding party and hers by the way then
danced to kendrick lamar's I love myself
Sex in the City mentioned it in 2003 a
lead character on Glee in 2010 enjoyed a
Salah gomess ceremony is this the most
depressing thing ever or is this a force
is this is this the perfectly logical
conclusion of feminism yeah I mean I
probably about really depressing and a
farce I think I mean I mean they
certainly don't think it's a farce they
believe everything that they're saying
but yeah I mean I don't even know what
that means to marry yourself I mean
aren't you already married to your stuff
I mean like can you separate from
yourself because if you if you can't
separate from yourself then you can't
marry yourself either I don't I don't
think you can even procreate with
yourself try try as I have I don't think
it's possible it seems like it's
slapping lipstick on a pig to use a
phrase because you pee these people are
alone and it's sad that they're alone
and it would be nice probably if they
found somebody and probably they could
find somebody but rather than say gosh
I'm alone and maybe I should change that
and somewhere I should do something to
change that instead what they do is they
say it's good to feel alone yeah I don't
feel terrible I feel great about it and
it's really sad a kind of related
question I guess as we're talking about
these traditionalism versus modernism
should women stay home to raise their
children did you make the right decision
I definitely made the right decision for
me I mean I
there is nothing I could imagine doing
other than this and I think that more
women probably should do it then and to
now but I really I hesitate to say every
woman should do something because then I
start to sound like the feminist you
know so I think what I definitely think
is that you this this thing you can have
it all you know you can work and you can
have your that's not true
right if you if you go to work then
you're making a decision to parent less
and to work less right you had you have
to there has to be a give-and-take
everywhere so it's a decision that
you're making but you have to know that
that's the decision that you're making
it's not hooray I'm gonna be you know a
stay-at-home mom at the same time as
being at the office all decisions closed
off other opportunities to make one
decision is to say no to many other ones
you know speaking of decision making
Chesterton said that heresy isn't the
promotion of Vice over virtue it's the
promotion of one virtue to the exclusion
of all of the others that today seems to
be consent you know most bars and
nightclubs now employ a notary public so
they can stamp your physical contact
consent forms in every single drunken
encounter after I think light hand stuff
I think that's the point at which you
have to go to the notary he will stamp
it then you can walk out together I
haven't read the statutes in a while why
does our culture elevated consent to be
more important than anything else
because we've elevated sex to be more
important than anything else so when
when you know well the person that you
are about to engage in sexual activity
with it's ridiculous to assume that you
should have consider it encompasses
happening that one of you doesn't like
you can't just say so I mean that's fine
I mean you probably should have written
consent if you decide to have sex with
someone you just met at a bar I mean who
who knows like what does who this person
is and what they're into I mean you
don't know you mean it could be Marshall
for goodness sakes you don't know who
you're gonna mate you've only talked to
the person for an hour exactly I hear a
little um yeah so I mean I think that's
the problem right we we've said that
that the sex is more important
then the connection or the intimacy or
you know love and so then we don't
actually know what we're getting it's
ironic to it what's ironic in the sense
that sex is
we're told the sexist meaning less it's
casual you can do it whenever you want
it's just like shaking a hand at but
also it's the most important thing ever
so if it's just casual if sex is no that
doesn't carry any moral weight then
sexual assault is no worse than slapping
somebody in the face right because the
sexual part doesn't make it any worse or
more grave or more serious but of course
we know that isn't that isn't true and
on this as we're as we're going back in
time we go to Chesterton we can go back
to Burke Burke wrote about the age of
ideologies revolution France proto
feminism he said is so prescient in
every way he wrote now all is to be
changed all the pleasing illusions which
made power gentle invidious liberal
which harmonized the different shades of
life and which by a bland assimilation
incorporated into politics the
sentiments which beautify and soften
private society are to be dissolved by
this new conquering Empire of a light
and reason all the decent drapery of
life is to be rudely torn off all the
super added ideas furnished from a
wardrobe of a moral imagination which
the heart owns and the understanding
ratifies as a necessary to cover the
defects of our naked shivering nature
and to raise it to dignity in our own
estimation are to be exploded as a
ridiculous absurd and antiquated fashion
on this scheme of things a king is but a
man a queen is but a woman a woman is
but an animal and an animal not of the
highest order and vomit all on edge paid
to the sex in general as such and
without distinct views is to be regarded
as romance and folly regicide and
parasite and sacrilege but the fictions
of superstition corrupting jurisprudence
by destroying its simplicity this
feminism
ultimately mean that a woman is but an
animal and an animal not of the highest
order
gosh well I lost you a little bit in the
feet so I didn't get what you just said
but I heard the end of it I
I don't know how to answer that I feel
like I feel like feminism makes it
certainly makes women into something
that they're not and I think you know an
animal I don't know I
please don't record me saying that oh
it's okay I turn the recorder off keep
it rolling keep I'm sorry yes
okay well now you know but I definitely
think it makes it makes women in well it
makes them an unhappy you know it makes
it makes them unhappy because they they
can't get what they want which is you
know love and intimacy and you know
someone to care for them and protect
them that's that's what we want that's
right and I don't think it turns them
into brutes like you know cows or
something and doesn't room into angry
Bulls II although but looking at that
first video
perhaps the it's an open question but it
doesn't I don't think he means that I
think he means it takes away all of the
things that elevate us above our animal
nature does it to men to actually turns
us into just brutes who have no sense of
chivalry and because they also don't see
any femininity in front of them nothing
to elevate men out of our maybe
knuckle-dragging
beast like nature but faith you're
enough to do that to us you're enough to
elevate this whole show if we ever had a
more elevated show than this usually
it's just like me and flexed walks or
something is absolutely in the gutter
faith thank you for being here we have
to move on to the mailbag so nice to see
you i you wouldn't you are so lovely and
nice and articulate you would never know
that you're Andrew Flavin's daughter
you would never it's a faith thank you
for being here tell me everything let's
move on to the mailbag oh my gosh
Marshall you monster
you all right fine we have to talk first
oh we get to talk about upside this is
pretty good how are your things to do in
2018 coming along mine is a work in
progress and you can read that as I've
abandoned all of them but there's
there's one thing that should there's
maybe there a couple I'm still keeping
around one thing that you should know if
you travel for business
I travel a bit for business you need you
know business travel is awful to book
it's awful if you have to change your
flight or this or that it becomes a huge
headache and becomes very expensive and
you frequently don't get great great
accommodations and great travel book
your next business trip on up side
dot-com when you do you will get the
better business travel experience you
deserve and a free pair of Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones more on
that in a second first here's why you
love upside it has great customer
service specialists who will look out
for you every step of the trip they will
handle any problem that might pop up
usually I'll just call sweet little
Alisa and weeping and have her talk to
the credit card company in the flight of
this and spare your friends and loved
ones and co-workers all of that headache
just use up side the the team is hard at
work 24/7 to make sure your flight hotel
and rental car all go off without a
hitch
they're available on demand by chat
phone and email whenever you need them
only up side monitors your business trip
around the clock proactively keeping you
posted on everything from the weather in
the city you're going to to changing
your flight home so you can just adjust
your meeting schedule I kid you not one
time I was in the UK and my airline just
decided that my return ticket wasn't
valid anymore and they didn't tell me
about this I didn't hear about this
until 15 hours before my flight back
across the world direct to Los Angeles
and that was a very frustrating and
expensive experience so don't let that
happen to you plus upside has great
prices for flights hotels and rental
cars now to get your free pair of Bose
sound like wireless headphones just
booked your first business trip with up
side by going to up side comm slash
cough FA Co V Fe Fe that is upside comm
slash cough FA to claim your Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones upside
calm you deserve a better business trip
headphones are available while supplies
last must be first up side purchase $600
minimum purchase required seaside for
complete details the lawyers make you
say that kind of thing but go to up side
comm / Co V Fe Fe okay let's get into
the mailbag we're running late we got a
hurry
got a Marshall stop it man why don't you
two let these people get one mailbag
question okay I'm sorry
we have got to sign off if you're on
Facebook in YouTube you have to go to
daily wire.com you're probably not on
YouTube because they keep censoring us
because they're colluding with CNN so
whenever we use a feed from c-span which
is owned by
the government you and I pay for it in
our tax dollars CNN will come in and
issue a copyright claim
because they want to shut us down
because our livestream had five times as
many viewers as CNN's ridiculous fake
News live stream and YouTube was happy
to accommodate and they shut down our
channel so you know probably you're not
watching on YouTube if you're watching
on Facebook go over to Daily wire comm
what do you get you get me the and
reclaim and show the ben shapiro show
the conversation i'm the next one up
baby it's gonna be the day before
Valentine's Day so ask me all of your
love questions but forget all that none
of that matters what really matters is
the leftist tears tumblr we listen we
have just watched all of those screaming
shrieking feminists at the beginning of
the show you're gonna need this
otherwise you're gonna be not only will
your ears be blown out by their awful
myung screams but also you will drown in
their in their Lefty tears so make sure
you go to deal while you're gone we'll
be right back
[Music]
let's get right into it first question
from Ashton hey Michael I have two
questions though each are of the same
life-altering value first what is your
favorite Scotch do you prefer a more PD
Scotch like Lagavulin 16 or a sweeter
Scotch like Macallan twelve the answer
is yes the answer is yes to that
question second do you enjoy smoking a
pipe as you do cigars I often find the
pipe smoking allows you to taste the
tobacco a bit more clearly than cigar
smoking keep living the cultured life
I much prefer cigars I have nine pipes I
have some wonderful vintage pipes these
Dunhill's from the 60s have a nice
Dunhill Mershon pipe that I'll
occasionally smoke but one it's very
frustrating at a tamp it and packet and
all that stuff you can get very high
quality tobacco but the tobacco isn't of
the same quality because it's not
longleaf filler as cigars are it's much
less expensive so I like that part of it
but I do prefer cigars cigars you just
clip it you light it up you smoke it I
also once read that's the the three
kinds of smoking tobacco correspond to
the tripartite soul so the cigarettes
are the pathos the appetite because
they're kind of addictive and you just
want to feed an urge and the cigars are
the ethos the spirited part and they go
outwards and they're big anything
Winston Churchill things like that and
then the pipe is the logos the logical
part it's both the stem and the bowl
male and female and it's the philosopher
sitting and contemplating by himself so
I'm more into the spirited part give me
the the cigar is and the ethos thank
good question from Nathan Michael can
you answer this question correctly
Nathan
Buffalo buffalo Buffalo buffalo Buffalo
buffalo Buffalo buffalo I hope that
helps from James
dear Michael what is your view on
churches giving to political candidates
it's the same view I have a personally
giving to political candidates which is
I don't put not your trust in Princes
where your treasure is there will your
heart be also we wrestle not against
flesh and blood but against
principalities against powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this world
against spiritual wickedness in high
places so I don't think the churches
should be donating to it I think
churches have better things to do with
their money that said we should
certainly
this Johnson amendment which since 1954
has prevented churches from endorsing or
opposing political candidates
theoretically because it actually only
stopped Christian churches and Jews and
Muslims from endorsing candidates and
even that's not quite true
it really only stops conservative
religious groups from endorsing
candidates in 2016 fully twenty eight
percent of respondents to a Pew Research
poll of people who attended black
Protestant churches heard their pastor
support Hillary Clinton over a quarter
absolutely no consequences whatsoever
just 9% of people who attended religious
services generally heard clergy speak
about a particular political candidate
but well over 1/4 of black Protestant
churches were preaching the anti gospel
of Hillary and that had no effect the
reason that they can't do it is because
of their tax-exempt status so the
government says you don't have to pay
taxes on your donations which of course
they shouldn't pay taxes on their
donations period but they said you don't
have to do that but you can't talk about
politics you know this really just
affects the conservative churches one
time I accidentally attended what's
called an independent Catholic Church I
think they're but they're like not in
communion with the Vatican they're very
right-wing more than the Society of st.
Pius the tenth and they're they're
probably I think I think it was
excommunicated but anyway I just went
there because they did a Latin Mass and
I wasn't I wasn't aware and because
they're not tax-exempt I heard the guy
at the podium he said in the homily the
quasi priest I guess he said you know
okay the dance will be on Thursday and
the picnic will be on Wednesday and
don't forget that Tuesday is your last
chance to stop the abomination
Administration on their path of utter
destruction and I really want my church
to be able to get down to brass tacks
like that and tell us to stop voting for
people who want to attack we want to
make nuns pay for abortions and who want
to kill more babies and and want to
raise my taxes all of which are terrible
I won't rank them right now on the show
so you know left-wing churches get to
endorse candidates but forget about that
the true Church of the left which is
Hollywood in the mainstream media they
constantly shill for Democrats so the
only people stripped of our First
Amendment rights or religious
conservatives it's time to do away with
the Johnson amendment
I hope Trump does it pronto president
Trump has been excellent on these issues
so
very well might it's a totally unfair
and on American advantage to the left
and it is significantly hasten to the
decline in our culture
next question from Patrick dear Knowles
at all after watching your this day in
history on King George the third and
remarking on his character and general
light handedness on the colonies I had
to wonder how justified was the American
Revolution if the levied taxes were to
pay for a war defending Britain's
colonies and the King was generally a
good guy was the US right to break away
why or why not
thanks and love to show Patrick I do
have certain certain Tory sensibilities
but no it was it was perfectly justified
it was quite justified because unlike
the French Revolution it was a
conservative revolution in America
George the third was a decent guy he was
generally more lenient and his
government on the colonies but he would
not assent to representation in
Parliament I'm slightly biased here
because two of my forebears fought in
the revolution one of them died John and
Simon Knowles John died at Bunker Hill
Simon also fought at Bunker Hill he was
young to enlist though he was 16 or even
younger and he was with Washington
Valley Forge and White Plains so I take
some family pride in that and wouldn't
want to make them frown from heaven I
think it was totally justified because
you have highly educated Englishmen in
America with a never separating culture
half a world away being taxed without
representation or very much respect from
their imperial government it's not that
the taxes were unfair it's that they
didn't have a voice in Parliament and
George wasn't going to give it to them
these colonists were not backwater
primitives who had no sense of
self-government
they weren't Colonials who didn't
understand Republic's or democracy or
Christianity or the culture it gave
birth to self-government
they were Englishmen of equal political
resources and tradition with their quasi
countrymen across the pond had George
assented to representation in Parliament
the revolution likely would not have
come but he didn't and so it came
luckily it was a conservative revolution
if it preserved tradition rather than
like the French tearing apart all of the
foundations of society banning
Christianity cults of raise and killing
priests beheadings regicide hours
because it was
British and not French was far more
orderly and it's a good thing that had
happened because it gave the us the
requisite independence and distance to
remain outside conversations of peace
with Hitler or getting bogged down early
in war efforts so that we could swoop in
and save the old world twice
back-to-back world war champions very
good thing from Sheamus do you think the
act of writing can be seen as inherently
narcissistic not the way I do it
definitely not the way I do it it
depends on what you're writing about if
you're writing an empty celebrity
tell-all memoir yeah maybe it's
narcissistic but if you're writing about
something that matters certainly not
but beyond narcissism I may be what
you're getting at too is that there's a
certain areas to writing or confidence
in stating your opinion and holding
opinion in telling others what to think
about the world as former president of
Yale rich Levin a lefty but you know
Richard Levin was a lefty but he's he's
right about a lot of things he observed
in a speech one time that the truth is
arrogant the truth is arrogant so we
have this new culture would say that's
your opinion man don't don't young my um
don't tell me what to think that's so
how arrogant of you the truth is
arrogant the truth is it's arrogant to
say that two plus two is four because
you're saying the two plus two isn't
three and if someone says that two plus
two is three then you're saying that
they're wrong and that they are less
learn it or less thoughtful or less
intelligent the truth is arrogant that's
okay it's all right as long as it's the
truth
the truth above all things from Mike
from Marlee Michael on your program you
have related reiterated the importance
of majoring in an academically solid
field like history or literature rather
than social science I'm a music history
major and throughout my studies the
history especially of early music is
highly politicized whenever the origin
is in any way based in Christian
theology or as a resultant from a church
musician discovering a new notation
technique there's an ear gut reaction to
turn every early musical innovation or
work into some analogy for extramarital
erotica or some anti religious
propaganda how did you combat the
politicization of studying something
like history it should be factual and
concrete but has become more subjective
overtime thanks Morley very luckily the
one thing Yale does very well is is the
history
Department actually and that doesn't
mean they don't have insane history
teachers there that teach nonsense but
there's a lot of freedom so they teach
everything and so you'll get Donald
Kagan or you'll get John Gaddis or
Charles Hill or you'll get good teachers
there in the field of history who can
learn you something and then you can
avoid the classes that are bad this does
happen a lot with history history can
become highly politicized what you have
to do is analyze the historical
techniques and make sure that you're not
learning history through some
historicist ridiculous lens and you have
to look for the good professors always
study the professor's don't who cares
what the sub the course subject is all
that matters when you're studying an
undergraduate is the professor I think
it's probably true of graduate school as
well that you will learn even if it's a
teaching something that you're not
necessarily the most interested in go to
the good professor who views the world
in a normal and rational and thoughtful
way you will learn much much more from
that person even if it's not in your
precise interest from Lisa hi my name is
Lisa I know I just said that I'm a new
subscriber thank you and would you would
like to know what your Kingdom series is
that you mentioned at the end of an
episode you're absolutely fabulous thank
you and my grandparents came from Italy
in Spain and I loved how you knew the
Italian word for cuckold and what it
means go to Nouveau Kota movies oh yeah
I heard that one a lot so that's another
Kingdom a shameless plug another Kingdom
is the podcast that Andrew Clavin wrote
that I performed it's now all out so you
can binge it just search for Andrew
clave ins another Kingdom where ever
find narrative podcasts are sold and
it's 13 episodes pretty long but the
first season is out there so go check it
out it's it's a lot of fun and people
are binging it and please leave a
five-star review it helps us to pitch it
to Hollywood and Polk and I in them when
they want a black list conservatives
from Michael mr. Noles I am hoping you
can but a few liberal points I've heard
this week concerning the economy word is
that members on the Left should not shy
away from debating the so-called booming
economy as it may not be as great as the
right makes it out to be their proof is
that is the assertion of points that the
stock market grew faster under Obama's
first year wages having grown much and
growth was higher in the three years
preceding Trump also the bonuses
being given a tour from tax cuts and of
being undercut by large swaths of
employees being laid off interesting to
hear your thoughts thanks that's not
that our friends on the Left are wrong
they just know so much that isn't so to
begin yes but Barack Obama came out of
the worst recession since the Great
Depression is he was so fond of telling
us and he had a terrible recovery it was
a recovery that never really happened
but nevertheless it had to go somewhere
so yeah yes the economy didn't grow
under Barack Obama he couldn't really
have fallen any further than it did
certain aspects of the economy we can
attribute to Donald Trump we were told
by all of the lefty predictors that the
market would tank and never recover
that's what Paul Krugman said if Trump
were elected not true it did tank a
little bit and then it shot right back
up we were told that we would never hit
three percent economic growth we've
blown past that something at Barack
Obama never could do Donald Trump did in
his first year consumer confidence is
high the IMF the International Monetary
Fund no-fun have done I know a fan of
Donald Trump said tax cuts tax reform
will help the global economy as for the
massive layoffs that's just total
nonsense the plural of anecdote is not
data so if some company lays people off
okay but as a matter of the US economy
we are the number of people who applied
for unemployment benefits in January
fell by a thousand to 230,000 which
keeps initial US jobless claims near a
forty five year low a half-century low
in unemployment economists polled by
market watch had a forecast of 240,000
in the seven days before we beat it this
is the tightest jobs market in decades
this is the best time for jobs in
decades it's finally causing wages to
rise which they haven't done in eight
and a half years hmm what happened for
the last eight and a half years I wonder
what what does that eight and a half
year period correspond with that I don't
know it comes out of a bat in my head
wages for private sector employees have
risen 2.8 percent in the last year the
biggest year-over-year gain since 2008
huh what happened in 2008 I can't think
what I add so strange unemployment is at
a 17-year low by other measures the
economy added a hundred eighty-five
thousand jobs the market is at record
highs but of course look the market is
going to correct at some point the
markets don't track day to day with the
presidency and markets go through
periods of boom and periods of bust
periods of bullish markets and bearish
markets
and so that'll correct soon I kind of
wish president Trump weren't tying his
success to the stock market so much
because it's going to correct it has to
and then Democrats are gonna lambaste
him for it but that neither the huge
booms are owing to Donald Trump and
neither are the busts from Neil hi
Michael the Irish Conservative
government FINA Gail pronounced FINA
Gail after years of mounting pressure in
Ireland has announced a vote on
repealing article 8 of our Constitution
this article pertains for the equal
right to life to both the mother and the
unborn child could you please shout out
to fellow Irish listeners like myself
that they can visit check the register I
II and take steps to ensure they are on
the register if you have an Irish
passport you're eligible to vote this
also applies to Irish abroad and
scattered across the world like myself
if you have a passport you can fly home
to vote to preserve the sanctity of life
in the Republic of Ireland every vote
counts thanks a million it would be a
damn shame if Ireland allows allows
widespread abortion that would be awful
so go check it out I'm happy to read
that from Nick Almighty Knowles what is
your favorite moment in the history of
the USA probably have to end on this one
guys what is your favorite moment in the
history of the USA also what brand of
smoking jacket were you wearing on
Tuesday night during the State of the
Union my favorite moment in the history
of United States is the landing at
Plymouth that's my favorite one
because it wasn't supposed to happen
everything conspired against it the
government of Holland conspired against
it the the English crown conspired
against it they the weather conspired
against her they were blown way off
course they were blown hundreds of miles
off course they were supposed to go to
Manhattan but they didn't even hit the
nice Harbor Boston Harbor that's right
above them they landed at this random
place in Plymouth and out walks
basically the only guy to the to only
people on the continent who spoke
English and and really
Squanto Squanto was the one who really
spoke English who had bizarrely lived in
London and lived in Spain and it was
it's just an example of providence of
divine intervention in the founding of
America it's undeniable if one looks at
the fact of it that bet is the best
explanation and it's unsurprising
because
our pilgrims it's like almost too
on-the-nose if you pitch this to
Hollywood Hollywood say no it's too
on-the-nose that's ridiculous gonna
believe that and that's followed by the
Battle of Long Island is another one
Washington was the Revolutionary War
should have ended the Brits should have
wiped them out in New York they should
never have been able to evacuate and
then then the weather changed and
Washington was able to get basically
everybody out without any casualties
just totally it should not have happened
and yet it had to happen because if to
me seems an evidence of Providence and
there were countless other examples
throughout our history and an answer the
most important question that is a Paul
Stewart double clasp double-breasted
smoking jacket with I think they're
cooler they Turtle clasps or something
they don't make it anymore that was
given to me by my godmother who is very
very nice she's ridiculous probably the
nicest article of clothing I'll ever own
and she gave it to me and then they
stopped making it a year or two later
because it turns out that the 18th
century 19th century dandy population
has starkly declined in recent years so
not a lot of people are wearing smoking
jackets if you can get your hands on one
or a vintage one or something do it they
actually work they keep the smoke off of
a lot of your clothing and they look
very fash and ridiculous okay that's our
show that's our week we will be back we
have a special show to announce coming
next week but I don't I'll leave you
wondering about it I hope you can
survive the weekend
check out another Kingdom if you want to
binge that over the weekend too and then
I will see you on Monday I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy bore senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jeshua of era the
Michael Nolt show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you